- [Instructor] So we have two,
three by three matrices here,
matrix A and matrix B.
And we can of course,
view each of them as a transformation
in three dimensional space.
Now, what we're going to
think about in this video
is the composition of A of Bs.
So you can think of this
as the transformation
where you apply B first, and
then you apply A after that.
And then we can represent that
by another three by three matrix,
which is partially completed here.
We have the first and
the third column here.
And so my question to you is
what is this middle column
where I have these three blanks?
Pause the video and try
to work through that.
All right, now let's work
through this together.
So one way to think about
how to construct A of B
is that what you're doing is
you're taking each of the columns of B
and you're thinking
about what would they be
under the transformation A.
So if you were to apply
the transformation A,
to this column, right over here,
you would get this column.
If you apply the transformation
A to this column,
right over here,
you would get this column.
So what we really need to do
is apply the transformation
A to this column,
to the middle column, right over here.
And just as a reminder,
how this transformation works.
A vector zero to three,
you can think of it as zero
of the one zero, zero vector,
the unit vector in the X direction.
Plus two of the zero, one, zero vector
plus three of the zero, zero one vector.
Now, when you're applying transformation,
instead of using these unit vectors,
you use the image of them
under this transformation.
And now in this situation,
instead of one zero, zero vector,
we are going to be using this thing,
instead of a zero one zero,
we're going to be using this thing.
Instead of a zero, zero one,
we are going to be using this thing.
So this middle column,
when it's transformed by this vector
is going to be zero, instead
of the one zero, zero one,
it's going to be zero
of the negative three,
negative three, three vector.
And then we have plus
two, plus two of the zero.
Let me do that in that purple color
of the zero, negative two, three vector.
And then last but not least,
you're going to have
three of the plus three
of then I'll do that in yellow,
the zero negative for one vector.
Now we just do the math.
So when you play zero times, all of this,
you're just gonna have a
zero, zero, zero vector.
So we can, those all go away.
And then you are left with, let's see,
this one is going to be
two times zero is zero.
Two times negative two is negative four,
two times three is six.
You're gonna have that,
plus three times zero
is zero, three times
negative four is negative 12,
three times one is three.
I could have written
this a little bit neater,
but hopefully you get the idea.
And then when we add those two things,
zero plus zero, is zero.
Negative four plus
negative 12 is negative 16,
six plus three is nine, and we're done.
We have just completed
the composition of A of B.